y llegó el momento de hablar de revista
de prensa y por supuesto rosa pérez más
después este viernes comenzamos con las
portadas y el papel de los medios en
cinco continentes que titulan la
invasión rusa en ucrania un día después
arrancamos con medios europeos luego
vamos a áfrica asia
latam y eeuu buenos dias raúl si
efectivamente hoy hay un maremágnum de
noticias sobre ucrania y esta pues
invasión rusa que está teniendo lugar
hemos seleccionado pues tres medios
europeos hemos querido mostrar una
pequeña representación de cada
continente aunque es pues muy difícil
primer en primer lugar este medio alemán
süddeutsche zeitung que titula guerra en
europa también hemos querido seleccionar
el liberación este medio francés que
titula lo impensable como comentábamos
ayer y por último del continente europeo
hemos seleccionado el observatorio
romano es que medio del vaticano que
titula la obra más oscura si pasamos
ahora nada una brevísima selección de un
medio africano a ver si nuestros
compañeros nos pueden ayudar con esto
hemos querido mostrar el sunday times'
de sudáfrica que titula como pie de foto
vemos aquí armas para el armada de don
luego en otro lugar hemos también
seleccionado el times of india' que
titula ruleta rusa putin va a la guerra
y por último este medio chino el 'global
times' muy aprovechan digamos que dice
rusia preparada para hablar tras
paralizar ucrania en un momento como
comentaba aquí en la posición de china
este aliado ruso que se encuentra en una
posición bastante complicada pues
respecto a apoyar o no esta invasión
seguimos en américa latina porque
también a los medios de nuestra región
abren con este tema no el comercio de
perú pueden portada esta foto que ayer
circuló muchísima éstos
y dice bueno putin invade ucrania a
sangre y fuego
seguimos con un medio de brasil el globo
a ver si lo podemos ver qué dice rusia
ataca ucrania y desafía la geopolítica
global y por último la tercera de chile
aquí lo veremos también esta foto no
pues sea muy impactante la guerra que
amenaza con convertirse en el peor
conflicto en europa desde
1945 desde el fin de la segunda guerra
mundial raúl vamos ahora entonces a ver
los eeuu rosas ya pasando por latam
efectivamente porque hemos seleccionado
en primer lugar el new york times y el
washington post disculpen rusia invade
ucrania tenemos también en la new york
times' que sí que titula guerra en
ucrania definitivamente y por último la
revista 'time' no con estas portadas tan
espectaculares a las que nos tiene
acostumbrados también el regreso de la
historia como putin destrozó los sueños
de europa con una foto de nana adjetivan
con las tropas rusas dirigiéndose hacia
mariupol
increíble haciendo también alusión a la
segunda guerra mundial rosa vamos ahora
a ver cuáles son los editoriales de la
prensa occidental vemos cómo se
posiciona le montó en francia país en el
país de españa y el tiempo en colombia
así es raúl empezando por el país que
bueno y sabemos que los editoriales son
estos posicionamientos estos estas
opiniones de los medios de comunicación
en este caso pues en la gran mayoría de
medios occidentales por no decir todos
se posicionan claramente contra esta
invasión rusa de ucrania el país lo que
dice es la cia acertó finalmente ucrania
está siendo bombardeada dice putin ha
optado digamos por corregir militarmente
lo que consideró en sus propias palabras
la catástrofe geopolítica
más satura del siglo 20 no el colapso de
la unión soviética y considera que esto
sólo es el principio de una grave
amenaza tanto por los países que
formaron parte del pacto de varsovia
como por la propia unión europea como
para el propio sistema de naciones
unidas lemont lo que dice es esta doble
deriva de vladimir putin considera que
por una parte el presidente está cada
vez más aislado y cogiendo no adoptando
una línea más dura y señala que pues los
países occidentales
tienen que adoptar sanciones más duras
si quieren frenarlo aunque eso afecte a
sus propias economías y por último el
tiempo de colombia considera que pues
hay que parar esta situación pero
evitando al máximo el dolor humano
también teniendo en cuenta que hay
potencias nucleares involucradas en todo
esto raúl rosa como abordan entonces
este escenario bélico los medios en
rusia pues los medios de massa pro
kremlin digamos como el consomé los que
haya fraude consideran en un artículo
que se responde a distintas preguntas
sobre la situación que tiene lugar en
ucrania considera pues no se puede
calificar de guerra lo que está
sucediendo en europa porque rusia lo que
ha lanzado esta operación especial tal y
como lo llamó el presidente ruso en
defensa de los civiles de la zona del
donbass y por otro lado también por
proteger su propia seguridad frente a la
expansión de la otan por otro lado en
otro otro medio el criado también
considera que pues a pesar de que está
siendo muy rápido lo que considera
imposición de paz en ucrania que algunos
soldados de las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas están abandonando sus
posiciones escondiéndose en las ciudades
y utilizando a los civiles como escudos
humanos por lo que culpa finalmente a
las fuerzas ucranianas de las posibles
muertes de civiles y finalmente raúl
pues también estos medios aseguran que
el futuro del nuevo orden mundial se va
a decidir en kiev cuando las tropas las
tropas rusas lleguen a la capital
ucraniana rosa gracias entonces por toda
esta información en entrevista de prensa
nosotros continuamos con más de nuestro
programa directo américa